pollinator decline is a grand challenge
in the modern world of the 200,000
species of pollinators honeybees are the
most well understood partly because of
our long history with them dating back
8000 years ago to our cave drawings in
what's now modern-day Spain and yet we
know that this indicator species is
dying off last year alone we lost 40% of
all beehives in the United States and
that number is even higher in areas with
harsh winters like here in Massachusetts
where we lost 47 percent of bee hives in
one year alone can you imagine if we
lost half of our people last year and if
those are the food producing people it's
untenable and I predict that in 10 years
we'll lose our bees if not for the work
of beekeepers replacing these dead
beehives we would be without foods that
we rely upon fruits vegetables crunchy
almonds and nuts tart apples sour lemons
even the food that our cattle relies
upon to eat hay and alfalfa gone causing
global hunger economic collapse a total
moral crisis across earth now I first
started keeping bees here in Cape Cod
right after I finished my doctorate in
honeybee immunology it was
imagine getting such a degree in a good
economy
and it was 2009 the Great Recession and
I was on to something
I knew that I could find out how to
improve bee health and so the community
on Cape Cod here in Provincetown was
ripe for citizen science people looking
for ways to get involved in to help and
so we met with people in coffee shops a
wonderful woman named Natalie got 8
beehives at her home in Truro and she
introduced us to her friend Valerie who
let us set up 60 beehives at an
abandoned tennis court on her property
and so we started testing vaccines for
bees we were starting to look at
probiotics we called it be yogurt ways
to make these healthier and our citizen
science project started to take off
meanwhile back in my apartment here it
was a little bit nervous about my
landlord I figured I should tell them
what we were doing I was terrified I
really thought I was gonna get an
eviction notice which really was the
last thing we needed right I must have
caught him on a good day though because
when I told him what we were doing and
how we started our nonprofit urban
beekeeping laboratory he said that's
great let's get a beehive in the back
alley I was shocked
I was completely surprised I mean
instead of getting an eviction notice we
got another data point and in the back
alley of this image what you see here
this hidden beehive that bee hive
produced more honey that first year than
we had ever experienced in any beehive
we had managed it shifted our research
perspective forever it changed our
research question away from how do we
save the dead and dying bees to where
bees doing best and we started to be
able to put maps together looking at all
of these citizen science bee hives from
people who had bee hives at home decks
gardens business rooftops and we started
to engage the public and the more people
who got these little data points the
more accurate our maps became and so
when you're sitting here thinking how
can I get involved you might think about
a story of my friend Fred who's a
commercial real estate developer and he
was thinking the same thing he was at a
meeting
thinking about it what he could do for
tenant relations and sustainability at
scale and while he was having a tea
break he put honey into his tea and
noticed on the honey jar a message about
corporate sustainability from the host
company of that meeting and it sparked
an idea she came back to his office an
email a phone call later and boom we
went national together we put dozens of
beehives on the rooftops of their
skyscrapers across nine cities
nationwide nine years later nine years
later we have raised over a million
dollars for bee research we have a
thousand bee hives as little data points
across the country 18 states and
Counting where we have created paying
jobs for local beekeepers 65 of them to
manage beehives in their own communities
to connect with people every day people
who are now data points together making
a difference so in order to explain
what's actually been saving bees where
they're thriving I need to first tell
you what's been killing them the top
three killers of bees are agricultural
chemicals such as pesticides herbicides
fungicides diseases of bees of which
there are many and habitat loss so what
we did is we looked on our maps and we
identified areas where bees were
thriving and this was mostly in cities
we found data are now showing that urban
bee hives produced more honey than rural
beehives and suburban beehives urban bee
hives have a longer lifespan than our
than rural and suburban bee hives and
bees in the city are more bio diverse
there are more bee species in urban
areas why is this that was our question
so we started with these three killers
of bees and we flipped it which of these
is different in the cities so the first
one pesticides we partnered up with the
Harvard School of Public Health so we
shared our data with them we collected
samples from our citizen science
beehives at people's homes and business
rooftops and we looked at pesticide
levels and we thought that there would
be less pesticides in areas where bees
are doing better that's not the case so
what we found here in our study is that
the orange bars are Boston
and we thought those bars would be the
lowest there would be the lowest levels
of pesticides and in fact there are the
most pesticides in cities so the
pesticide hypothesis for what saving
bees less pesticides in cities is not it
and this is very typical of my life as a
scientist any time I've had a hypothesis
not only is it not supported but the
opposite is true which is still an
interesting finding right we moved on
the disease hypothesis we looked at
diseases all over our beehives and what
we found in similar study to this one
with North Carolina State there's no
difference between disease and bees and
urban suburban rural areas diseases are
everywhere these are sick and dying in
fact there were more diseases of bees in
cities this was from Raleigh North
Carolina so again my hypothesis was not
supported the opposite was true we're
moving on the habitats hypothesis this
said that areas where bees are thriving
have a better habitat more flowers right
but we didn't know how to test this so I
had a really interesting meeting an idea
sparked with my friend and colleague and
Matt and fellow TED speaker and we
thought about genomics kind of like
ancestry DNA or 23andme have you done
these you know you spit in a tube when
you find out I'm German right we've
developed this for honey right and so if
we have a sample of honey and we look at
all the plant DNA and we find out i'm
sumac and that's what we found here in
Provincetown and so for the first time
ever i'm able to report to you what type
of honey is from right here in our own
community
honey DNA at genomics test spring honey
and Provincetown is from privet what's
privet hedges what's the message don't
trim your hedges to save the bees right
I know we're getting crunchy here and
it's controversial so before you throw
your Tomatoes move to the summer honey
which is water lily honey if you have
honey from Provincetown right here in
the summer you're eating water lily
juice in the fall sumac honey we're
learning about our food for the first
time ever and now we're able to report
if you need to do any city planning what
are good things to plant
do we know the bees are going to that's
good for your garden the first time ever
for any community we now know this
answer what's more interesting for us is
deeper in the data so if you're from the
Caribbean and you want to explore your
heritage
Bahamian honey is from the Laurel family
cinnamon and avocado flavors but what's
more interesting is 85 different plant
species in one teaspoon of honey that's
the measure that we want the big data
Indian honey that is oak every sample
we've tested from India as oak and
that's a hundred and seventy two
different flavors and one taste of
Indian honey provincetown honey goes
from 116 plants in the spring to over
200 plants in the summer these are the
numbers that we need to test the habitat
hypothesis and another citizen science
approach you find out about your food
and we get some interesting data so
we're finding out now that in rural
areas they're 150 plants on average in a
sample of honey that's a measure for
rural suburban areas what might you
think do they have less or more plants
and suburban areas with lawns that look
nice for people but they're terrible for
pollinators suburbs have very low plant
diversity so if you have a beautiful
lawn well good for you
but you can do more you can have a patch
of your lawn that's a wildflower meadow
to diversify your habitat to improve
pollinator health anybody can do this
urban areas have the most habitat best
habitat as you can see here over 200
different plants we have for the first
time ever support for the habitat
hypothesis we also now know how we can
work with cities city of Boston has 8
times better habitat than its nearby
suburbs and so when we work with
governments we can scale this you might
think on my tombstone it'll say here
lies NOAA plan to flower right hey
it's exhausting after all of this right
but when we scale together when we go to
governments and city planners like in
Boston the honey is mostly linden trees
and we say if a dead tree needs to be
replaced consider linden when we take
this information to governments we can
do amazing things this is a rooftop from
Fred's company we can plant those things
on top of rooftops world
why to start restoring habitat and
securing food systems we've worked with
the World Bank and the presidential
delegation from the country of Haiti
we've worked with wonderful graduate
students at Yale University and Ethiopia
and in these countries we can add value
to their honey by identifying what it is
but informing the people of what to
plant to restore their habitat and
secure their food systems but what I
think is even more important is when we
think about natural disasters for the
first time we now know how we can have a
baseline measure of any habitat before
it might be destroyed
think about your hometown what risks
does the environment pose to it this is
how we're going to save Puerto Rico
after Hurricane Maria we now have a
baseline measure of honey honey DNA from
before and after the storm we started a
new Macau this is right where Hurricane
Maria made landfall and we know what
plants to replace and at what quantity
and we're by triangulating honey DNA
samples you might even think about right
here the beautiful land that connected
us that primed us all to citizen science
to begin with the erosion the winter
storms that are getting more violent
every year what are we going to do about
this our precious land well looking at
honey DNA we can see what plants are
good for pollinators that have deep
roots that can secure the land and
together everybody can participate and
the solution fits in a teaspoon if your
hometown might get swept away or
destroyed by a natural disaster we now
have a blueprint suspended in time for
how to restore that on earth or perhaps
even in a greenhouse on Mars I know it
sounds crazy but think about this a new
province town a new home town a place
that might be familiar that's also good
for pollinators for a stable food system
when we're thinking about the future now
together we know what saving bees by
planting diverse habitats now together
we know how bees are going to save us by
being barometers for environmental
health by being blueprints sources of
information little data factories
suspended in time
thank you